over the past 10 years as you know we
have adopted many groundbreaking and
controversial Public Health policies
from Banning smoking in the workplace to
requiring chain restaurants to post
calorie counts to Banning trans fats to
posting Le grades and restaurants
prohibiting smoking in pars and on
beaches together those and many other
policies have helped New Yorkers live
longer healthier
lives city is now years
200 but as far
as
[Music]
and
Vegeta we all know that is not
we are
[Music]
serious
H remember for many years the standard
soda size was 6 oz not 16 it was six
then it became 12 and people thought
that was huge some people say just talk
about the problem raise awareness I hope
it results uh in
[Music]
change
friends and all of the rest of the
people that live on God's planet and so
while other people will bring their
hands New York City doing
something of we have a responsibility as
human beings to do something to save
each other to save the lives of
ourselves our families our friends and
all of the rest of the people that live
on God's planet